un des problèmes les plus préoccupants à
paris celui de la circulation pour
circuler il faut effectivement pour voir
rouler il faut aussi pouvoir s'arrêter
il faut pouvoir avoir des parkings les
pouvoirs de paris le préfet de paris le
préfet de police ont déjà mis au point
certaines mesures des parkings des
souterrains ils ont élargi des voies
rétrécies des trottoirs
mais d'ores et déjà les pouvoirs publics
sont en train de préparer de nouvelles
mesures pour connaître ces mesures nous
avons mené une enquête
voulez-vous la suivre pour faciliter la
circulation dans le centre de paris en
particulier dans les quartiers
d'affaires
les pouvoirs publics étudient
actuellement la possibilité d'interdire
totalement la circulation des
automobiles en recommandant aux
automobilistes l'utilisation des
bicyclettes
mais que pensent les parisiens de ce
projet
personnellement j'ai fait du vélo dans
mon plus jeune âge étaient à l'ascb donc
dans ces conditions je pense que on peut
quand même appuyer sur les pédales
malheureusement c'est on est arrivé à un
siècle les gens n'aiment pas faire un
effort
on a personnellement je préfère la
voiture que les bicyclettes ce site est
faut pédaler
vous avez déjà fait la bicyclette oh oui
oui j'en fais avec plaisir n'y avait pas
tant de voitures
si vous êtes contre ce projet absolument
c'est un retour pour moi de 50 ans en
arrière
comprenez l'appui cycle est c'est fini
c'est fini et que là où je suis c'est
crise ou non vous êtes favorable à ce
projet ah oui mais moi je suis tout à
fait je suis tout à fait pour c'est un
instrument très très pratique je pense
que pour une femme c'est idéal pour
aller chez son coiffeur pour les à ce
petit cours pouvaient absolument plus
sur qui les place vendôme pouvait plus
stationner avec une bicyclette très très
facile
monsieur que vous êtes au courant d'un
projet qui consiste à réserver certains
quartiers à usage des cyclistes oui j'ai
entendu parler de ce projet d'ailleurs
j'ai déjà commencé à ses disciples est
épais je m'exerce ont tous les matins et
le soir pour rentrer chez moi
hugues d'ailleurs chain métier
sédentaires je travaille dans un bureau
donc ça me permet de prendre de
l'exercice merci je voulais santé au
travail merci
ah non je suis très surpris et que
pensez vous de ce projet
part je n'en pense rien c'est mais pour
l'instant je trouve que c'est assez
marrant parce que vous rendez compte
remplacer les voitures pour les
bicyclettes
en plus de ça les mini jupes très
intéressant pour nous l'ancien on vous
demande justement d'utiliser
prochainement la bicyclette qu'est ce
que vous ferez que je le ferai face à
gré puis quand vous portez je vois une
religion puisque sera pas gênant pour
vous non parce que c'est une jupe
culotte à chaque fin de cycle est patent
ben mon choix que ce soit excellent
parce que nous allons voir 3 millions
véhicules dans peu d'années et
évidemment ça résoudrait les problèmes
de circulation ne sera pas mal vous
savez prendre tout ça nous arrangerait
bien sa revanche mais que tout le monde
se croit sa déco je suis un peu la
circulation permettra de circuler pour
vous oui d'accord ça pour ça oui
pierre gobbo je crois que vous avez été
séduit par ce projet a finalement à tout
à fait séduit et voyez vous pouvez le
constater je me suis mis je suis ce
projet parce que c'est une chose très
importante et il faudrait que tous les
camarades de l'actualité télévisée fasse
la même chose les rues de paris serait
ainsi dégarni on roulerait beaucoup plus
vite et pour le sport quels progrès et
bien l'appel de pierre roubaud a déjà
été entendu et dès cet après midi une
équipe de l'actualité télévisée
partaient un reportage à bicyclette
[Musique]